hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to some
christmas specials we watch because
they're so well done that we love them
others we watch because they're so odd
and strange we can't help but love them
but every once in a while you get one
that's kind of in between one that you
feel like a little ever won into but
somehow also a lot of ever went into and
the crowning champion of that is the
Charlie Brown Christmas every year we
watch this simple sweet but let's face
it kind of cheap short while its beloved
by millions all over the world there
aren't some people who scratch their
heads and simply say I don't get it not
the obvious message or the fact that's
supposed to be simple in its approach
but they don't get why this is a holiday
classic why is their merchandise selling
like mad for it every Christmas why does
everybody show it to their kids why do
people act like it's the greatest
holiday special ever made with no
problems at all element growing up I
liked peanuts fine but I've got more
into their other projects like Snoopy
come home or the Halloween special he'll
even their second Christmas special I
thought was actually a little bit more
interesting than the first one I just
thought they had a lot more atmosphere
and character to them and while I didn't
mind the original Christmas special well
admit I was kind of confused why
everybody obsessed over it as well what
was the magic formula that seemed to win
everybody over and more importantly as a
lot of people are starting to ask is it
overrated
well first a quick rundown of the
special Charlie Brown is feeling very
Charlie brownie as he wants to
understand the true meaning of Christmas
he's told that by directing the
Christmas pageant he'll be forced to
understand what the true meeting is all
about and under a time limit as well as
expected he's not a very good director
unable to control his actors and also
bring in a very sickly looking tree but
after Linus explains the very literal
meaning of Christmas quoting the Bible
everyone including Charlie Brown find
the beauty in the tiny tree and make it
up to look nice and it just sort of ends
there yeah we never get to see the
pageant we have no idea if it goes well
or not it just sort of ends
then singing that's it to some this
would seem like lazy writing why have a
pageant if you're never going to show it
hell even the things going wrong with
the pageant are not traditionally funny
they just keep dancing while he shouts
directions and the fact that the acting
is often stilted the animations
obviously on a tight budget and several
sake ways with Snoopy Schroeder and
others that tie in little to the plot
hey this is bad for the same reason to
love our things we don't like are bad so
what are the elements that make people
love it so much let's look at the
technicals first for example the music
the music is wonderful bringing a
low-key but still very warm jazzy feel
to the entire thing as soon as it opens
and we hear a soft children's choir sing
about the arrival of Christmas it sets a
very particular mood that signals from
the very beginning it's not going to be
like your typical happy super energetic
Christmas special it's not bouncy or
overly emotional it's very mellow and
calm this music is such a staple at
Christmas that even the peanuts piano
theme is played on the radio around this
time and that's in every peanuts special
yet we still associate it with this one
the most we just saw group it in with
how good the rest of the music is next
let's talk about those detours like Lucy
forcing Schroeder to find the perfect
song or Charlie Brown just talking to
himself about Christmas or Snoopy just
being Snoopy a lot of these don't really
further the plot that much so why have
it well looks like the Halloween special
it helps establish the environment of
Christmas we watch the Great Pumpkin
every Halloween because they do all the
things you're supposed to do on
Halloween go trick-or-treating Bob for
apples make costumes it's impossible not
to think of the holiday the Christmas
special does this too just in a
different way
there's tons of specials that show Santa
opening gives hugging family so this one
decides not to go that route it instead
focuses on the mixed feelings children
can have this time of year during a
holiday about loving and caring for
people it's easy to get lost in an
emotional whirlwind with all the
charities and stories about the less
fortunate people forget there is a very
grim side to the idea of Chris
and the greatest Christmas specials
always point that out this one captures
an element of childhood that not a lot
of other specials do the confusion and
that simple stuff you seem like family
circuits like Oh what does this word
mean I mean like emotional confusion
childhood isn't all fun and games it's a
strange and uncertain time and because
we teach kids that Christmas is more
than just Santa and presents it forces
their minds to venture to deeper and
more thought-provoking places that's
what peanuts usually got so well the
uncertainty sometimes there are clear
answers sometimes there aren't we don't
know why things never go right for
Charlie Brown it just kind of what life
throws at it which steps into another
element of childhood that's rarely
talked about in specials Polti the other
kids are relentless to him they never
let up they are just so mean and a lot
of people would say oh those kids are
just so mean to and why but people
forget they are judgmental they are
mocking they do tease anything that's
different and since Charlie Brown is not
your typical upbeat kid of course
they're gonna make fun of them but
they're not just typical bullies they're
kids like any other kids if they were
bullies that would make them very black
and white and not as interesting but
every single one is relatable and has
some aspect of childhood that you
remember and probably happened in your
childhood now Charlie Brown's not happy
about this but he keeps going hoping one
day he'll find answers to all the
questions he doesn't know but is open to
the very real probability that he won't
so he has to take comfort in the little
things like the optimism of not getting
his kite wrecked or one day being able
to kick the football or a tiny tree that
can be seen as beautiful and it wasn't
until I really thought about that tree
and embracing its simplicity that I
realized that's what I'm doing with this
special when the animators finished
making this they showed it to the studio
and they hated it they thought it wasn't
gonna work at all and it was awful but
and I already paid for it so might as
well run it but because it was so simple
and so different from anything else that
was on TV people really enjoyed it and
afterwards the studio just shrugged and
said hey what do we know it's like the
studio was all the kids that were making
fun of the tree and the tree itself was
this special
remember what I was talking about how
you never see the pageant go on in this
well maybe the reason is because you're
watching the pageant right now think
about it literal kids many of them
amateurish giving wooden performances
against simple backgrounds with piano
music talking about the meaning of
Christmas this is a Christmas pageant
just on TV and the same way you admire
the effort and simple one that goes into
a pageant the same way you admire this
even when lioness dates the very obvious
meaning of Christmas he cused the lights
talking to an audience that isn't there
look at that nobody's in those seats so
where's the audience well it's us we're
the parents of this well-meaning special
and while the message is very clear
about not letting marketing get in the
way of the true meaning people forget
this came out in 1965 and this was not a
common message yet especially for
younger kids even the Grinch which came
out a year later focuses more on
Christmas not being about materials this
directly says it's not about advertising
be much more specific than most specials
were at the time even the quoting of the
Bible this was seen as kind of a daring
thing to do you didn't see this in many
Christmas specials surprisingly again
especially for children but that's
exactly why they did it because nobody
else was and I think that's what people
relate the most to with this special
there's no bullshit about it every
production has some manipulation in
order to make you feel something but
this one covers it up less than the
others it's not trying to dazzle you
with big songs grand animation or
hilarious jokes it's letting you
appreciate how much you can get with so
little the same way Charlie Brown found
a lot of worth in a seemingly simple
tree the same way we find a lot of worth
in a seemingly simple special its
perfection is in its imperfection and
just like our main characters
understanding of Christmas it can't
always be explained it just kind of has
to be felt it would have been so easy if
Linus quotes the Bible and Charlie Brown
goes to a nativity scene and they all
sing around that but no he's taking what
line is said and
applies it he's inspired by the story of
Beauty coming from such simple places
and he goes to prove that with the tree
in doing so his simple act inspires the
rest of the kids to see that same beauty
and apply it themselves we all seen
nutjobs quote their religion but never
actually follow what they preach say
they're supposed to be kind to others
but be really mean-spirited and
judgmental instead this is showing the
importance of following through with
your actions not just saying it but
actually practicing it putting it to use
in real life shit
this is really good it's really good
because it does everything in its own
simple way and it's a way we're not used
to on Christmas specials but we can
still very easily relate to is it gonna
win everybody over no but it's not
supposed to some people will find great
joy and its simplicity others will want
something more challenging and complex
and there's nothing wrong with that you
can find that any Arthur Christmas or
the Christmas carols or whatever but to
its credit I think there's more to this
special than meets the eye
just like there's more to Christmas than
meets the eye it isn't just about
spreading the story of Christmas it's
about practicing it yourself it's
showing the importance of applying it as
well as celebrating it it's about
putting that effort and love towards the
things that are most important anyone
can just quote scripture but it takes a
special talent to inspire and make
others do better and for a lot of people
that's what this special does yeah it's
basic yeah it's tilted yeah it's not
that funny but I can't help but feel
like it kept into something more than
the majority of other Christmas specials
do something simple but still speech to
the majority of people watching in the
end maybe it isn't such a bad little
special after all
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out you know I got an
email from someone telling me about this
charity that he worked for called
gleanings for hunger and I looked into
and I said you know why not uh this
looks like a very nice charity that is
trying to do exactly what sounds like
feed the hungry not just in North
America but in Asia South America and
Africa pretty much anywhere they can get
to places that need it the most you know
we live in a time where we can throw
away food if we're not hungry and sadly
so much goes to waste and instead they
utilize it and they use it to feed those
who have none they try to inspire hope
they try to inspire faith they try to
show that there's people out there who
care about them and that they can help
if you go to their YouTube site you can
see a ton of videos of people who are so
thankful and people who have so little
but are just so grateful for what's
being given to them this is a community
of people coming together to do
something that's so important trying to
take the little bits the low shards
they're so often just tossed away and
turn it into something that can help
keep so many people alive
if interest if you can not only donate
to this organization but you can also
volunteer you can help make a difference
and send literally a million packages of
food out there so if this sounds like
something you'd be interested in
definitely click on the link and check
it out
you